I'll bet you're thinking look at these
fascinating beautiful exotic creatures
wait could I impress my friends by
plopping one of these on a sushi roll
and serving it for dinner ha stop don't
go back these are new - brakes marine
snails with no shells and many of them
defend themselves by releasing chemicals
that make them inedible these particular
Goethe pranks are found in the waters
off the coast of Indonesia the neuter
branks are very adaptable you'll find
them from Antarctica to the tropics
their striking colors what make them so
attractive to underwater photographers
are what warn predators to back off
enjoy the colors just don't think of
putting a nudibranch in your seafood
salad